want to play a game i want to play a
game with
everyone in times square
i'm gonna guess about how old somebody
is without even
looking at them i think it's impossible
check this out
i'm gonna ask you to close your eyes and
when i say go raise up one of your feet
and try to keep your balance as long as
you can
all right sounds good want to play along
at home
find a safe spot just in case you
stumble and get ready to close your eyes
and pick up one foot we'll put this
counter on your screen
when you put your foot down open your
eyes and check the time
are you ready yeah three two
one go higher long as you can nice job
keep it going
this is hard doing great hey
what are you like a yogi or something
i'm dead
focus i'm gonna guess your age after
this try not to hop if you can avoid it
keep it up keep it up keep it up you're
doing good
i'm trying to keep it together oh my god
okay time's up how'd you do can your
sense of balance really predict your age
six seconds you're between 55 and 65.
i'm 59. 51 seconds my friend
you are under 25. and how old are you
19.
all right you lasted about 23 seconds
you're about 30 years old
and how old are you i'm 29.
what's going on here how does this game
work stay tuned
i'll guess your age and show you how
your brain uses
senses in astonishing ways
our senses are how we decode and
interpret what goes on around us
and for every one of us it's a little
different
our senses go way beyond balance
why do some of us see the world this one
might be a little bit heavier i feel
like you're trying to trick me
and hear the world it peers through my
soul
and experience the world differently
we can fool our senses well i think it's
getting bigger
i know it's not right why can't we
fine-tune them
it's so hard master them can we even
find
a new sense could we even unleash super
senses
so get ready to have some sense knocked
into you on
brain games
[Music]
this is times square in new york city
sensory overload
on steroids distractions leap out at us
everywhere we walk
look or listen it's pretty much a
miracle that our brains don't get
overwhelmed and just shut down
completely
but if you had to rely only on the five
basic senses in a place like this
you wouldn't last a minute you know your
five basic senses right
[Music]
i just touch there's smelling
there's taste smell
sight smell taste
touch taste smell sight and hearing
did you remember them all sight touch
sound taste and smell they're the five
fundamental ways your brain receives
information
these senses make up your brain's
control panel to the world
combine them and you get super senses
for example combine elements of your
senses
touch sight and sound and you get
balance
a super sense you use every day without
even thinking about it
[Music]
we tested balance in our game earlier do
you remember your time
take a look at this chart science says
the older you are
the harder this game is does your time
match up with your
age and how are these predictions so
accurate
knowing how your brain changes over a
lifetime we can observe how your senses
interact with the world and predict how
old you are
but that's just the beginning we're
gonna dig deep to explore not just the
five senses you know about
but lots of others you didn't even
realize you had
let's start with the game quick find a
seat
and stick your right foot out slightly
start to turn it in a clockwise motion
now take your right index finger and try
to draw the number six
from the top down
[Music]
whoops what happened did your foot
suddenly stop
or change direction no matter how hard
you try
you probably can't do it the reason is
because the left hemisphere of your
brain
controls the right side of your body and
your brain's
motor cortex gives instructions to only
one side of your body
at the same time give different
directions to your right arm and your
right leg
and you'll get the wrong results but i
want to know
how can we hack our brains and use our
senses to do the
unexpected to find out we customized
this bike with a set of differential
gears to control the handlebars
turn the handlebars to the right and the
bike turns to the left
that's not so hard right so we told all
our fans in times square i want to ride
and offer 100 bucks to anyone who can
ride this bike
20 feet we'll check in with them later
to understand what it will take to
unlock our super senses
let's start by testing two of our basic
senses against each other
with this game see the two dots moving
across your screen
do these dots pass through each other
or do they bounce off one another and
change direction
what do you think it's hard to say right
well this time pay close attention
[Music]
aha clearly the dots bounce off each
other
well this is what's called a cross modal
illusion
where one sense affects how the other
operates in this case the sound of a
collision
changes how your brain sees the dots
interact
this is because our sonic instincts run
deep to show you just how deep we set up
a listening station where unsuspecting
volunteers
can test out a new brand of headphones i
would love for you to give me your
honest opinion
about our new headphones would you like
to try them out bring it let's go try
this one on throw them on
check it out pick it up
it's so clear excellent
oh i'll be jamming on the subway with
these let's do it
nice at first our volunteers are picking
up nothing but good vibrations
love this song
what they don't realize is we are
controlling what they hear from behind
the set
but what do you think will happen if we
mix in some unsavory sounds
offering up a selection of noises
ranging from the merely obnoxious to
get me the heck out of here
the nails that were coming down that was
really weird because it was like the
back of my mouth
the teeth were like
chris now it's like a balloon okay
you love that one is it spice girls
[Music]
it peers through my soul
[Applause]
the styrofoam starts on my back and it
just works its way up like this
and then it comes up here and then it's
on my head oh i hate it
[Music]
sounds like um sorry somebody's throwing
up
when i heard the barf i felt it in my
body like
right here in my stomach that made me
know
so what's going on here why do we have
such a physical reaction
to nothing more than unpleasant noise
how does your brain sense sound and why
does it respond so
physically to some sounds but not to
others
measured in something called hertz sound
waves move through the air as vibrations
the higher the frequency the more
powerful the vibrations
[Music]
the highly sensitive systems of your
inner ear receive these sound waves and
send information about them to your
brain
remarkably many sounds trigger your
amygdala
the part of your brain that controls the
fight-or-flight response
suggesting our brains have actually
evolved to associate sounds of a certain
frequency
with danger or distress
these sounds aren't language but they do
communicate
they are meant to trigger an immediate
biological response
so those shivers you feel are probably
tied to our ancient survival
instinct each of your senses on its own
has
powerful connections to your brain but
combined
your senses are more powerful than you
might expect
[Music]
brain games has set new york city on a
super sense collision course
we've offered a hundred dollars to any
of our fans in times square who can
conquer
this backwards bike how's your day going
uh so far so good how old are you i'm
11.
you're gonna be riding this bike about
20 feet that way if you can get to the
other end there's a hundred dollar bill
nice and crisp there waiting for you and
i get to keep it
you get to keep it what do you do for a
living i'm actually a bike car
fantastic well listen this might respond
differently than most bikes
but it is mechanically possible to ride
but you can't your feet can't touch the
floor
you gotta actually ride the bike the
whole way you think you're up for the
challenge
i think so are you ready oh my god yeah
i'm totally ready let's do this
okay here you go ready
yes let's do this
[Music]
i think you got to start again really
hard all right go for it
why isn't riding this bike as easy as
well riding a bike
even if you know that to ride the
backwards bike you must steer right to
go left
and left to go right in the moment your
brain
can't help but react wrong
let's look at the root of this brain
fade starting with the gain
take your thumb and pointer finger on
the hand you used to write with
holding them about a quarter of an inch
apart as if you were grasping a small
screw or
tack now without looking gently
touch the nails of those fingers to the
tip of the index finger on your other
hand
how many distinct points of contact can
you feel on your finger
did you say two now again without
looking gently touch those fingers to
the middle of the opposite forearm
what do you feel now can you still
distinguish both fingers
probably not that's because there are
far
fewer nerve endings near the surface of
the skin on your forearm
the high concentration of nerve endings
in your fingertips send
tons of detailed information to your
brain
[Music]
to see just how sensitive your senses
can be stanford university's dr allison
okamura has met us in central park to
play a game
our experience of our bodies includes a
lot of different senses like
pressure and touch she's got a low-tech
brain hack designed to stimulate your
senses
and fool your brain with just a chair
a blindfold and a relaxing massage can
dr
okamura make people question how they
see their own bodies
let's give it a try i'll let you put
this on cover your eyes
to give you a sense of what our
volunteers are about to experience
let's play a game
cross your index and middle finger now
touch the tip or bridge of your nose
with the space where your fingers cross
does it feel like you're touching
two noses this is an example of what is
called perceptual disjunction
your brain doesn't expect your fingers
to be crossed and since it's rare for
the outside
of both fingers to be touching something
your brain
feels two separate noses
believe it or not it was the ancient
greek philosopher aristotle who was said
to have discovered
this little brain game
and more than 2 000 years later brain
hacks like this
are still going strong once these
volunteers are blindfolded dr
okamura stimulates nerves in their arms
which
remarkably triggers confusion in their
brains
think about your nose does it feel like
it always does
it feels like my nose is getting bigger
okay
i can't hold on to my nose
what's happening in our volunteer's
brains
so i had a mental picture of almost
standing outside my body watching
my nose grow and i i tried to keep my
hands on my nose
but i couldn't keep it steady it just
kept on coming apart
how about now anything
feels bigger like
longer my nose is getting skinny
kind of long and skinny i'm pinocchio
right so what's happening here
well you don't normally have to keep
touching your nose to know where it is
right that's because the nerve endings
in your skin give you a mental model of
your body's shape and size
stimulate your nerves unexpectedly and
your brain sensory signals get scrambled
well i think it's getting bigger but i
know it's not right
now i'm going to use this vibration and
touch underneath your arm
stimulate an oppositional set of nerves
and even more surprising things happen
all right
[Music]
do you feel anything different now uh
yeah now it feels like my nose is kind
of
getting smaller that's not possible is
it
maybe your brain is telling you
something i'm still a little bit
confused
a little bit freaked out more than just
your sense of touch
this is proprioception sometimes
described as how we feel
sensing your body's position during
movement
these new sensations can cause us to
feel something different about our own
body shape
what mental picture is your brain
forming of your body right now
with this one a little piggish
your nose is getting squashed huh oink
oink
that was weird it's surprising that
the brain can be tricky with you buddy
okay thank you thank you all right you
can take off your blindfold
that's so weird amazing amazing
blindfolded it's easy to see how
proprioception is a super sense your
brain might take for granted
but even with your eyes wide open you
might be surprised at how your senses
can't be fooled
let's play a game to show you what i
mean
which of your five basic senses is most
directly linked to your appetite
the sense of smell is a common answer
well imagine you're hungry
which of these two plates do you think
you'd choose for a meal
this one or this one
most people say the one on the right
because of the smaller plate size
your brain misjudges the amount of food
to be greater when in fact it's the same
amount on both plates
this visual misperception of relative
sizes is called
a dell booth illusion but you can turn
it to your advantage
switching from a 12 inch plate to a 10
inch plate
can cause you to consume 22 percent less
food
you'll waste less too and you'll even
feel like you're eating more
when it comes to appetite seeing the
food on your plate is
as important as tasting or smelling it
but how does your sense of sight measure
up to touch to find out we've invited dr
okamura to play another game with us in
long island city
take a look at these two boxes we've
placed
weights inside them both using logic and
experience
your brain might think the bigger box
weighs more
right
[Music]
now as you can see you have these two
blue boxes in front of you guys that
want you to evaluate them just kind of
walk around get a sense of their
dimensions study them
some bots now on my queue i'm going to
have you lift up the box in front of you
and just get a sense of its weight all
right
ready go
oh man that's heavier than i thought
this is lighter i think this is lighter
soft positions all right let's do this
when i say go
the same thing go
our volunteers can't peek inside
but which one was heavier to you this is
this one feels a little bit heavier but
they're allowed to lift
each of the boxes
okay you both agree yes yes
do you both agree that the small one
seems heavier
oh yeah certain absolutely sir everyone
seems to agree the smaller box weighs
more
i feel like you're trying to trick me
we've placed weights inside of each of
these boxes
we asked our volunteers without peeking
to tell us which is heavier
that one seems heavier definitely yeah
definitely
uh this is lighter yeah this one feels a
little bit heavier
which i thought it would be lighter but
it's not
i think let me do it once
huh okay so when you had just
looked at the boxes when you just looked
at the size
which one did you think would be heavier
um i guess this one because
it was just so big so it's bigger yeah
initially you're gonna think
bigger means heavier yeah i was thinking
the same thing too
turns out this game requires more than
just your sense of sight and touch
your brain also relies on motor learning
a kind of muscle memory
super sense to gauge the weight of the
boxes
so which box is really heavier bring
that one over here and then read the
reading from the scale in pounds
okay
14 pounds 14 pounds yeah all right so
now
we know the lighter box is 14 pounds
let's bring in the heavier box heavier
bottom all right
14 pounds
wait what what does it say 14 pounds
14 pounds it's the same exact thing but
we we really yeah how does that even
work though like
why well when you first pick up the box
you have this
expectation that the larger one will be
heavier and so you apply more force than
you need and
that makes it wind up feeling lighter in
a way but you lifted it multiple times
and you moved it around
and you really developed an internal
model of what the weight
was in other words your motor sensing
system figured it out
it knows that it requires the same force
to lift each box
but the cognitive perceptual part of
your brain refuses to accept that
conclusion
so it still thinks that the smaller box
is heavier
what does that tell you about your brain
it has lied to me
i do not trust anything anymore ever
we live in the matrix oh god no
[Music]
but there was one result i want to look
at again
when two weight lifters tried the
experiment they had a different reaction
than most
that was yours compared to a plate
they're close but which one was heavier
too i think
i think they're the same yeah that means
to me they felt the same they felt the
same
their extra experience lifting weights
helped them
sense the boxes weighed exactly the same
as the saying goes practice makes
perfect
is that why people in times square are
having such a hard time with our
backwards bike
[Music]
it's so hard all right go tiago
oh no it does not work
to help explain our pedal-powered
problem we turned to dr andy murray a
neuroscientist from columbia university
so what's going on in the brain why are
people getting so
tripped up trying to ride this bike if
you want to understand neural networks
and why it's so difficult
to change a learned motor skill you
could think of a riverbed
so initially water flows in a completely
random way
right and then eventually you start to
form a path in the sand and the stones
and
water that comes after this will flow
much smoother and faster and in the same
way
when you learn a new motor skill the
flow of information through your brain
is initially rather random and
convoluted
sure but when you repeat that skill over
and over again
pathways become strengthened and the
information flows through the brain much
faster
and smoother let's see if your brain can
deal with a little randomness
take the random words we put up on the
screen and make it into a sentence that
makes sense
give it a try
[Music]
did you get times square is very busy
go ahead and try it again
this one reads let the good times roll
now for round three
this time you probably figured out lemon
is the sourest fruit
was this last sentence easier to
unscramble than the first two
doing a task once and learning basic
directions your brain begins to carve a
path for this task
so perhaps the brain best suited to
conquer our backwards bike will belong
to someone who has spent years dedicated
to riding a bike
charles jason welcome to brain games
thank you happy to be here
neuroscientist dr andy murray andy nice
to meet you pleasure
so you're a professional bmx rider right
right i've cycled for about
20 25 years okay i ride freestyle bmx
i ride fixed gear as a commuter in the
city you know i
definitely was up for the challenge
mastering the backwards bike won't be
easy
even for a professional bike rider so we
gave
charles the backwards bike for two weeks
to see if he could rewire his motor
memory with a little extra time
and speaking of time let's play a game
that might turn back the clock
using one of your senses look at these
images of five common and popular scents
cinnamon orange pine tree peppermint
and lime now we're going to take them
away
and lay them face down in the original
order
can you remember from just a few seconds
ago what the original order was
[Music]
did you get it right were you able to
recall cinnamon
orange pine tree peppermint then lime
did you even start to smell the scent of
the images we showed you
this is because unlike touch sight and
hearing
your sense of smell has some unique
abilities
your nose's olfactory bulb is actually
part of the limbic system with
intimate access to your hippocampus and
amygdala the parts of your brain
most linked to memory and emotion you
might say your memory of those scents
took you on a kind of time travel
recalling a whiff of cinnamon or fresh
pine experienced long ago
and helping you remember the order of
the cards we showed you
this is one way senses affect our idea
of time
a super sense all its own and for our
next game we're back in times square
with mentalist mark salem
to see if he can stop time all together
did it stop working completely it did
quick pay attention i'm about to show
you a magic square
where the numbers 1 through 9 are
arranged so every row
and every column even the diagonals add
up to 15.
but this is brain games so there's a
twist some numbers will be missing
you must fill in those missing numbers
and
try to keep track of how long we give
you to solve this magic square
are you ready here we go
[Music]
okay time's up think you have the answer
did you place the numbers four
seven and one in these spots if so
good work but how long do you think we
gave you to solve this puzzle
five seconds ten actually we gave you a
full
15 seconds but it felt like a lot less
right this is because mentally
stimulating or challenging tasks
actually make time seem to pass faster
and here's another game that relies on
your ability to estimate the passage of
time
pay attention to this short video clip
[Music]
how long would you say that clip lasted
the answer eight seconds now
watch this clip
[Music]
so which clip was longer the two videos
were actually the same length
how could that be the more complex
sequence of events should trigger
heightened neural activity in parts of
your brain that have been shown
to dilate your sense of time that's why
for most people the first clip seems
longer
than the second one
but is it possible to stop time entirely
using his mastermentalist skills mark
salem is trying to stop
and even change how these people sense
time
yeah it's 11 30. is it working
no it stops is it an expensive watch
yeah then it's time to get it fixed it's
it's like almost one o'clock
you like i jumped it like no i didn't
something you
moved through time now is it working
yeah yeah and what time does a correct
watch say
are there any correct 32 11 32 and yours
says
11 36 11 36
so you're already in the future mark's
ability to stop time
relies on his understanding the many
minute ways that people sense and
interact with the world
allowing him to lead our senses to
experience only what he wants to
it's a talent that mark has perfected
with years of practice
while on the other side of times square
charles has been practicing with our
ultimate test of super sensory skill
the brain games backwards bike tell us
what have you been doing with this bike
the first time i got on it i wasn't able
to go a foot i couldn't get my feet to
the pedals
steering was very counter-intuitive it
was certainly like being a five-year-old
again
your brain automatically wants to use
this pathway that is previously built
so not only are you learning a new skill
you're overcoming this old skill
so you've been practicing yes and during
that time you didn't ride your normal
bike at all right
right so there was no regular steering
only the reverse steering
are you ready to give it a shot yeah all
right let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
great job charles that was amazing
so those two weeks of practice paid off
huh absolutely
it was a lot of fun to be able to do it
with an audience
it started to feel natural a little bit
absolutely
so does that mean that he was creating a
new neural pathway right yeah i think
there's definitely been some remodeling
there
with two weeks to practice charles has
reprogrammed the part of his brain that
learned to ride a normal bike all those
years ago the experiment
isn't quite over okay so you've been
practicing on the inverted one for two
weeks
you haven't touched the original bike i
haven't been on my old bmx bike
in two weeks all right well we have a
surprise for you here on brain games
we're bringing your original bmx bike
out here
to see if you can still ride it oh yikes
you guys think he's gonna do this
[Applause]
i think this is gonna be very difficult
i'm eager to see what happens
[Music]
we've given one professional bike rider
the chance to master his senses and do
what our brains
tell us is impossible ride a backwards
bicycle you ready to give it a shot
yeah all right let's do this
and after two weeks of dedicated
practice charles conquered his brain
great job charles thank you that was
amazing so those two weeks of practice
paid off huh
absolutely what do you think will happen
when charles climbs back on his own
personal bike
[Applause]
[Music]
come on charles come on charles wow
[Music]
charles motor memory fails him after
only a few
feet what used to be so intuitive has
now become the opposite
what happened charles no that's tough
right
interesting right it's like those two
weeks carved a new neural pathway in
your brain and all of a sudden this
became
unnatural right so this is a really
incredible example of what we call
neuroplasticity
so researchers have found that your
ability to learn and relearn different
motor tasks are linked to a particular
part of the brain called the cerebellum
and what this area does is it compares
what we're trying to do
with what we've done in our uh past and
so it slowly updates the pathways
um as we learn new skills so now you're
stuck with this new pathway and it's
difficult to ride your bike
how did it feel it felt strange strange
right familiar but strange like
something was off
definitely well as it turns out you'll
be able to quickly
unlearn the new skill and regain back
your mojo a couple of days even you'll
be great yeah and i think i'll be taking
the subway home
yes you will all right well thanks for
being here charles you were amazing
thanks jason
we can trick and fine-tune and train our
brains into mental sensory mastery
but can we go beyond our five basic
senses
let's play a game in three rounds
take a good look at these red and green
dots
they're going to disappear and when you
see them again
tell me if you think any of the dots
changed
[Music]
what did you think change or no change
time for round two
did you see any change this time
remember your answers
it's time for our final round
so which rounds did you say had changing
dots
you said rounds one and three you're
right
there was no change in round two we
asked you
which exact dots exactly changed
that might be too much for your brain to
handle but studies show
most people say the image changes even
though they can't say
exactly what has changed you might say
those of you who answered correctly
sensed something you didn't actually see
does that sound like a sixth sense our
super sensei
master mark has developed his super
sense of micro
observation the ability to sense what
others cannot
to read minute details of body language
and attitude
what if i told you that i could
guarantee
i could tell with virtually a hundred
percent if somebody is lying
i'd say you were lying what if i
said let's test this on our next game
all right
by getting these people to tell a little
white lie mark can
uncover who's actually telling the truth
in a moment i'm going to ask you all to
make a drawing
okay it could be a sketch all right a
doodle something you've drawn before
something you've never drawn before
the important thing is that it'd be a
drawing of something okay
your 15 seconds begins now you should be
drawing already because
already seven six come on you know the
word
five four three two
one markers on the floor
right pass them all to jason
the drawings nice thank you jason mix
them all up
very very mixed up mix mix mix mix mix
mix
making this into the most random shuffle
in the universe
all right all mixed up all mixed up
drawings two
drawings two okay excellent here's what
we're going to do
i'm going to try through identifying
through body language and other sorts of
techniques
who drew what i'm going to ask you if
you drew this
simply say no i'm going to see if i
can't pick up those subtleties that say
that you're lying or that you're not
did you draw this no did you draw this
no do you draw this no did you draw this
no okay i've got to say before mark uses
his super senses to tell who is lying
look at each of our contestants closely
is there anything you notice about their
behavior
who do you think is lying let's see if
your super senses are as good as marx
i see her on stage every single night
one person looks how the other people
are responding they turn their head
only one person did that that was you
this must be yours is that correct
yeah i'm impressed
let's watch that again
you draw this no that's right mark
caught my head swivel to watch the other
players did that occur to you
[Music]
what other clues can he find now that
you are more aware of what micro clues
to look for
try again you draw this no
draw this no throw this no how about
this time
[Music]
catch the tell that's the clinton though
that's where somebody
wants to tell the truth but they're not
so they do a little this
okay and that's what you did
[Music]
did you get it this time according to
mark
this super sense can be learned by
anyone who pays attention
there's a million things going on in our
environment
simultaneously but i think people are
walking
through life not seeing everything
you draw this draw this no draw this
no you shouldn't stare some of the eyes
when you're
lying when we stare people in the eyes
it means we're uncomfortable and we want
power over them one person locked into
my
eyes didn't change it at all that was
you
[Music]
i know this stuff and yet i still
couldn't help myself
i still couldn't help overdoing things
to try to not look like i was lying
i just think that's an amazing skill i
wish i had that i really think that's
the coolest kind of magic
now that you've had some practice let's
play a game to see if you can find
another faker see these four smiling
faces
all of them look happy right but if you
had to guess who was
the happiest who would you pick
[Music]
if you said this smile you're right but
what makes one smile
happier than another
it turns out there are 19 different
types of smiles but only one is a true
smile of pure
enjoyment called the duchenne smile
this smile results from small muscles
around the eyes
that contract when the emotion of joy is
felt
involuntarily creating a genuine smile
that is almost
impossible to fake other types of smiles
express or conceal
all kinds of emotions so if you spot a
smile that isn't on the up and up
look to the eyes
[Music]
watching your eyes is just one of the
ways mark is able to conduct his time
square lie detector test with only one
sketch left it's not hard to guess who
drew it
but can mark tell what the last person
drew
without looking at his cart
that's when it got crazy
mentalist mark salem is about to use the
powers of his super senses to feel the
imperceptible
and read the mind of our volunteer let
me
i'm just going to run through something
uh animal vegetable mineral do not
respond
animal vegetable mineral uh some kind of
animal some kind of animal but it's not
an animal it's an animal it's not an
animal it's
it's it's part of an animal it's part of
an animal but it's also part of
lust it's part of the lust ball animal
it's part of lustful animal which is you
it's part of you
okay oh feeling that way this is uh
february this is um a valentine
can we see anybody draw what that's when
it got crazy i was like
what like he literally figured out what
i drew
and um just by looking at me
wow yo very impressive
very impressive blown away thanks guys
oh my god
incredibly using his power of
micro-observation
a dilated pupil or a twitching muscle
it's all mark needs to sense
hearts a waterfall a surfer riding a
tidal wave
eggs and bacon even an ocean liner
whatever's on your mind
can anybody learn how to do this i knew
you were gonna ask me that
yes everybody absolutely could do this
but surely there are limits right like
it's not like we can stop a random
person here in times square and read
their minds yeah of course we could we
could do
this right here in times square but
something of this magnitude
really deserves a bigger stage
mark has taken over times square to
attempt a massive
mind meld and prove his super sixth
sense
is the real deal we're gonna use what
are called zener cards or sometimes
esp cards it's a number of different
shapes
one is a star one is
a circle one is a square
we have the wavy lines
and the last one is a plus sign
what about you at home take a look at
these five cards again
a star a circle a square
we have the wavy lines and a plus sign
now i want you all to concentrate on
the car that reaches you the deepest
i'm going to try to see which one you're
sending me
[Music]
oh
who chose the wavy lines
did you pick that one too judging by the
show of hands
mark's prediction matches the choice of
over half our fans in times square
hey jason over here how are you doing
how did you do that
your mind is capable of all sorts of
cool things see that but can you tell me
what the mechanics were behind the trick
well no i can't tell you that that's a
swear word public and everything
if they turn off the audio in fact i'll
make sure the audio goes off yeah and
i'll explain all this stuff to you
the last hour has shown we may not yet
telepathically communicate brain to
brain
we can absolutely listen and pay better
attention to the signals we get
from our own brains this one feels a
little bit heavier
it's so hard
your internal guidance system commands
some pretty incredible missions
each and every day from helping us
perform superhuman feats
to tricking ourselves into believing the
impossible it feels like my nose is
getting bigger
to making sense of the avalanche of
input layered into every facet of our
world
your autopilot is a pretty accomplished
navigator
don't forget to enjoy the ride
[Music]
you